i want to introduce you to uh dayton
hypernova now this is a fresh
this is a fresh local nobody's nobody's
tapped this yet
i just found out about this morning he
only had 35 subs but i played a little
bit of a stuff this morning and now he
has 82. so
i want to introduce you to uh dayton
hypernova okay ready
uh the title of this is this video
there's a bunch of videos but this video
is bigot
brother preaching some arrogance to a
lady on the porch check it
we've got out rivers so i mean we've
actually gotten per capita
more healthcare than anybody else
here
so this guy this dayton guy he's 32
years
old uh
he lives with his still lives with his
mom and dad
uh his brother actually looks like a
relatively nice house it is it is
it's old his brother
uh his older brother lives or his his
brother
uh lives across the street uh and he
brings his kids over whatever
he hates his older brother he hates his
dad he hates everybody
let me show you why my brother's out
there talking to somebody about
something i don't know
what but all i know is that man beats me
in this house
when i'm in drag this man who's standing
out there on the porch
preaching some fake ass gospel about
himself
some fake ass gospel no folks that's not
sticks
uh well that's about all for now
so he's a uh a drag queen
he lives in the house and he's my dear
brother beats me
he is accusing his brother of beating
him which because
i'm a kid
[Laughter]
when he's a male chauvinist drunk ass
hermit in this house without a job
without a life
beating me when i'm half his size less
than half his size
in front of family in front of his
parents in front of his older
or his younger sister who's older than
me who knows this and doesn't care
i was right in front of her the last
time one of the last times
not even the last time there was one
other last time she attacked me
it was on my birthday weekend of my
birthday
this man is nuts and he's out there
talking some preachy ass gospel [ __ ]
now let me tell you a little bit about
his brother his brother who's sherman
and i'm not doxing anybody he says the
names in the video this guy's name is
earl
schultz uh he says it in the videos his
name is earl schultz
uh his brother's sherman he doesn't like
his brother because his brother
is a trump supporter
and thinks that his younger brother earl
here
earl has a mental disease because of the
sounds like my kind of guy exactly hey
you know what uh what's his name
sherman sherman remember in dayton we'll
hang out buy you a beer
about saving the neighborhood
what he really means is black like kick
out the entire portion of the
neighborhood which is like 70 of the
population hold on can we hear him out
i i hear you bud i get it but can i hear
this the sherman guy
because he doesn't like people he
doesn't like poor people he doesn't like
why does he live in dayton ohio
the worst place to live if you don't uh
he has like women
he hasn't been with a woman in the six
years that he's lived in this house
he does not do anything he he never
leaves the house he shouts at
football games and basketball games and
goes on racist
tirades and rants at the during the ways
during the football games because
listen i have had running backs drop a
ball when i'm in [ __ ]
playoffs yeah quit digging earl you
struck oil i like your brother
i get it he's a nice guy he's awesome
can we can you hand him the phone yeah
can we talk to him
does he have a channel oh we do talk to
him don't worry
the football games and the basketball
games and everything where
most of the athletes are black he shouts
racist things to all of him
that man is so out of control and i'm
just getting video footage of all of
this
and he's talking to some lady on the
porch right now about
some nonsense that he wants to do for
the neighborhood the man beats
the [ __ ] out of me in this house 32
years old
and it's what you were thinking is if he
beats the [ __ ] out of you you're 32 why
don't you move out yeah
fight back a little messy boy okay so
little [ __ ]
that's the introduction but there's
there's more there's there's uh there
there's there's a little bit there's a
little bit more here there's a little
bit more
i like that he just hides upstairs oh
very messy no no it's that
because uh the kids keep i really i said
that the kids keep their toys in this
box
the the parents have their grandchildren
over absolutely because the parents have
the their daughter lives across the
street actually
so they you know they let the kids play
yeah that's fair yeah
i love this guy he's like my brother's a
hermit he's a loser he never leaves the
house
you don't ever leave the upstairs you
film over the bastard you [ __ ]
agoraphobic creep
so his his brother is usually downstairs
and he watches his nieces and nephews
while his uh
while his sister is working because he's
less likely to something
than the other guy exactly of course
this is his brother
it was like the movie jack or something
clean your [ __ ] mirrors my dad's
sitting in the
hallway downstairs by himself i think
the
kids that they're babysitting are right
there in that room or the right wait
listen hey [ __ ] randy rhodes do us
all a favor okay
well randy rhodes was blonde i guess
that doesn't work hey zach wilde
do us all [ __ ] favor you're gonna
mope around in that bathroom all day why
don't you clean off the mirror
you seriously marty jeanetti can you
[ __ ] do something with yourself
seriously long-haired cousin joe coletta
i've had it with you
also like joe they're spitting i don't
know what he's spitting
he's not he looks like every dude that's
still in a band
yep that's like oh man this year we put
together really good tape and uh
you know colombia's looking at us and
you're like you're 32 years old
mike it's funny you say that most of his
youtube channel is him and his band
no it is of course
i got a friend that works at sony said
he's gonna come to our show this weekend
so that's kind of a big deal we're
probably gonna get a major label debut
because
you know if there's one thing that's
selling right now it's metal albums
danny's they call them meth rollins
and my older brother
who's a alcoholic who beats me in this
house
he punches me in the face and he keeps
telling me over and over again that i
was the worst member of degeneration x
and the nwo and i keep reminding him i
was the only one who was in both and i
keep telling me you were the worst
member of both and then he beats me
the kids that they're babysitting
he took his dogs outside what an animal
this guy took his dogs outside
you know to pee
imagine some [ __ ] creepy brother
some [ __ ] failure in the family hides
upstairs all day
and films you through windows and does
captain's logs about you every [ __ ]
15 minutes
captain's log supplemental royce's
gone downstairs and enjoyed a light
snack and now he says ranting and raving
as he plays video games he beats me
he beats me so
this is uh now remember the parents
these parents i my heart breaks for
these parents
because they're trying to take take care
of their kids and whatever so
they the parents take them out to a nice
dinner at outback steakhouse
i thought you said a nice dinner and
then you sit out back i know which which
one pick one
for dayton oh okay so fancy dating
dinner
okay yeah i i i see how you were
confused though yeah i don't know
in ohio that's where you go for your
50th anniversary exactly
outback this man so he's filming that's
his brother
[Music]
so this dude is already being a skutch
yes he's already be like
by the way this guy seems perfectly
normal oh you'll see he is an
actual normal sitting there on him just
[ __ ] that guy
well they're trying to eat dinner and
have a lovely meal and someone says are
you sure it's not a put on i'm positive
and you'll see why in a second
too many people out there running
because like
i'm gonna skip ahead so he oh his hands
like that because
uh just really quick he has cirrhosis
and he has ferocious and in his videos
he
blames his brother because stress causes
cirrhosis
and he's stressed and that's making him
flake up that's not
he blames yeah he blames him uh he keeps
accusing his brother of his brother
beating him however
this guy films everything there's not
one video of a bruise a scratch or
anything
psoriasis
[Music]
it's caused by stress that's the last
thing you see
by the way you see that that's the last
thing you see when you meet joe biden
by the way i love how this brother is a
problem in the parents of the brave
everybody else is the problem
you are withdrawing from a family meal
so you can live stream or film it and
complain and point at your brother and
say like
like clearly you're right everyone else
is at fault here
yeah it's uh pariah
you're right sorry i apologize it's
caused by stress i'm at the same price
so this is them leaving the balloon
that's the mom oh yeah that's the dad
poor dad
[Music]
no i'm not going to take her according
to sherman i hit him in the eye at some
point
tonight according to sherman i hit him
in the eye at some point yeah the police
came because you hit me in the eye and
gave me a black
eye so what what's turning out is he's
actually the violent one and they've
called the cops but we we
remember when you came out of the room
and you start beating everybody
this person
so now they walk outside that's the mom
not a man who dresses as a woman you
just don't
and he let it happen over and over so oh
you got to hear this line this
sorry this is the best line check this
out listen to this i mean you're just
going to just pretend like it's not real
but it is
[Music]
you don't let a man beat another man not
not a man who dresses as a woman you
just don't
you don't let a man beat another man
with the
caveat of well at least not a man
that dresses like a woman so you're
admitting by the way
that you're a man who dresses like a
woman that you
are men who dress
as women thank you for that yes i
appreciate that thank you
this will be used as evidence
he let it happen over and over and over
again and now he's saying i
hit him in the eye i've never touched
that man in the eye in my life
so now it gets crazy in the car i've had
to pull you off
how many times i've never done these
things i have never laid
my hands on and the mom of course does
confirm that he runs out of the room and
he just starts
beating on his mom and just screaming at
her mom in my entire life
sherman i've never done that dad doesn't
want to talk sherman
charlie mace goes who paid for dinner
earl
it's true no one's going to believe you
because you're an idiot an [ __ ]
you have a large fist that run into me
no he just said that i beat you mom
have i beaten you well you get in my
face i've never
oh my god i've never done what he just
said i have never done what he just said
tell him to cut you off yelling at you
okay i have reacted to mom reacting at
me that is the most i've ever done i've
never
done any of these things that you are no
mom you don't mom i'm going to ask you
did earl run out of his room yes in a
violent rage
and attack me and punch me in the face
i've done that i've done that i've
punched sherman
police okay look some people got punched
i'm not saying what but i'm not the kind
of guy who does those things
and of course the piece of the
resistance
on christmas this is on christmas
remember
earl is early it's not the violence is
here
oh yeah okay okay so earl is very
so sherman is sitting on the couch
downstairs with his family on christmas
with a puppy with a
puppy in his hands i wanna really kind
of
oh no no no i wanna i wanna highlight
you guys
what an unhinged madman this guy is this
guy's clearly a psychopath
sitting here with his puppy on christmas
what a loser lunatic
stop feeding me when did the police are
refusing these okay addie
this is why you don't join the
conversation i guess i shouldn't have
but i just know
that's the pregnant sister who lives
across the street addie this man
this man this man beats
me sherman can you stop bullying my
father
can you stop bullying your sister
you're not if you're a boy you're a boy
[Music]
he hates his parents the police come and
arrest her
let's do it let's breathe let's do it
let's let's
read me let's do it
christmas time is here
[Laughter]
okay actually here you go i got i got
this here you go
[Music]
there you go royalty free we got it
happy birthday
now you heard that glass breaking that
wasn't stole cold steve austin coming in
uh no earl
earl had a wine glass in his hand and he
smashed it
on sherman's face on his brother's face
watch
smashed the wine glass over his head
it's amazing so there's some blood and
wine is what you're seeing this man has
been
waiting just through this in front of a
little baby he throw this in front of a
little baby
he's trying to murder a little baby god
you're prospecting scary
what is their problem yes addy
he beats me he beats me murdering
they throw this blaster
you shot my family's not the most
sane family but
this is like beyond any like this is
insanity this is
like i grew up i grew up in a pretty
troubled household but
nothing like this on a regular basis
holy [ __ ]
so you tried to murder a little baby
what is wrong with you
idiot dude you're trying to murder a
little child no one's trying
and a lot of people might be saying
sherman's acting crazy you have to
understand
shorman has to deal with this lunatic
brother filming him all the time
screaming at him telling him call me a
girl actually to be fair no he doesn't
see
either one of these two losers could
move away from home
that's just the thing i i'm with you
but sherman is definitely not the bad
actor here no
now i want to uh i want to show you well
actually you know what first
i got to show you the little number that
sherman's wearing in this because he
does actually get into the into the
mirror
here you go this man beat him
he looks like scott weiland he's dressed
like scott weiland
let's get instead of scott weins he's
scott weiland
get it cause he's got it
my hatred this man beats me
he's been doing it you smashed a wine
glass
on him he look he looks like
every dude you've ever met that has a
story about how he was
almost in soundgarden
you know what it was i didn't have the
look they were looking i actually
i actually uh i was way better singer
than chris cornell oh [ __ ]
but i didn't have the look they were
going for so you know it's like and to
this day i mean me and chris are cool
it's like whatevs you know they got the
you know worked out best for everybody
now i'm here living at home
[Laughter]
then he ambushes his parents his mom's
trying to watch her stories
by the way both parents are retired they
have some savings but they also live off
of social security but middle class
families what you're looking at
around can see it except you okay mom
are you just telling us do you have a
problem yeah it's me that's a problem
for getting beat down
you have a problem bro
explain it explain what you're saying
you have a problem what is the problem
you have a psychological problem explain
to me what this is
now you're damaged i guess i get beat
down therefore i'm damaged by a guy who
beats
women in dresses or women that's what
i'm saying
oh you are a man i don't know what
happened to you but you're a man
obviously you were born a man yes i was
born male 1
you had a girlfriend not that many years
ago yeah that was uh
nine years ago obviously in love that
has nothing he's 32 which
again i want to remind everybody this is
a 32 year old man
the last one the the the there's there's
a couple
a couple fun things that you guys need
to see
uh before we get to this one this is the
dad now you haven't seen much of the dad
the dad even though he lets his son live
there rent free
the dad pays him a hundred bucks to do
like tasks around the house right
so the dad tries to give him some money
watch the dad fired him
in his underwear by the way the dad
you're fired
you did not pay me the week that i got
beat down days before my birthday you
did not pay me
that man in that room sleeping in there
beat me down body slammed me in front of
you and your wife
you are the two people that brought me
in this world in that manner's world and
i
work in this house below minimum wage
and i don't yes i do if i'm not going
through a conversation about
oh 100 a week is not adequate pay for
what that he's paying no rent and living
there for free
and the dad's asking him to help out
around the house
it's not adequate i'm not going to have
a conversation about that i'm going to
tell you that you owe me
money and you know that you owe me money
you owe me money
for the week of january 12th 2019
that
last year he took his father's credit
card and ran it up three thousand
dollars
and never paid him back and doesn't care
and
doesn't care now i know we're going to
go right now i just wanted to go the
last little the last little thing
before we go it's only a minute 48 then
we'll then we'll head out
a week later this is a week later the
title of this video is my dad can't
drive me to cincinnati to meet christina
ricci
richie sorry richie owen benjamin's axe
okay dad i need to
i need to get into cincinnati okay bye
and i'll get you you have a car out
there you just drove me home have
a car your hat is your mother's car
i don't have a car oh my god
why can't you drive me to cincinnati you
can
if you get me a car i'll thank you
dad i need to get to cincinnati by a
little
i would thank you it would be really
good to get there by noon
if you get me a car i'll take you i'm
not gonna find you a car to drive
you have a car in a driveway there how
look at my lips i don't have
a car i don't own a car
why can't you talk
dad dad listen listen to me social
security for
850 a month that's
that's not even half of what i have to
spend
on my kids you don't spend anything on
your kids that are in their 30s that
live in their house
who besides the one you pay below
minimum wage to who do you pay for
you're who i don't want to hear me
mentioned talk about another one
twenty dollars an hour is not below yes
it is
what he pays him twenty dollars an hour
i wanna make two
dollars work around the house what an
[ __ ]
it's not even that anyway so yes it
it is it's not that bad you're ignorant
no no i'm relevant to the era
he's relevant to the era
uh i just posted the link in there by
the way if you guys want to check in on
him please
do uh 20 an hour
doesn't pay rent 32 years old blames
everything in his life on everyone else
uh i just want to welcome dayton
hypernova
to the locale factory welcome welcome
earl
we will start making a lot of fun with